what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
2024 I'm so excited to talk about
Sasquatch Sunset I walked out of your
movie last night thinking to myself one
of the greatest things in the world how
does this movie exist thank you for this
I did not know I needed this in my life
I mean it before we dig into the movie I
need to give an extra special shout out
to filo our sponsor this year filo is
wonderful they let us uh hit Park City
and celebrate Independent films and they
are also a groundbreaking company that
puts the power to Greenlight films in
the hands of fans and creators if you
want to learn more about filo check out
their website
film. okay David I'm going to give you
these duties can you give everybody a
brief synopsis of Sasquatch Sunset um
well it's it's a it's a year in the life
of a of a family of sasquatches uh you
know fighting for survival in the in the
Pacific Northwest Wilderness very very
succinct there I like that in our uh
press notes the log line was just a year
in the life of a singular family that
was before the screening yeah he wasn't
giving much I mean it's kind of nice to
keep it short and sweet like that um
looking at the writing of the film can
you tell us the core idea that started
it all but then also if you had a break
story moment something that convinced
you that this concept could sustain a
featurelength film well Nathan and I had
made a short that we had it Sunday in uh
2011 called Sasquatch birth Journal 2
and um and that uh and and I don't know
and that that did really well and and
and uh and so I don't know we just kept
joking about expanding on that that that
world and um we just joked about it
enough to where it became real
eventually but then then it took a long
time to get together beyond that oh yeah
I'm going to come back to that um
Kristoff and Riley briefl so you you get
this script I'm sure the script is
wonderful but it feels like a concept
that might be difficult ult to fully
wrap your head around and believe as
even possible just based on the page
alone so after you read it what were
some of your biggest burning questions
for the two of them in terms of you know
getting the information you needed to
make you believe that this could be a
film we could actually make I think that
my um I I I got a call first and they
said you know they said like the zelno
brothers are making a movie about
Sasquatches and I was like great hire me
um and then I got the lookbook in the
script and it's such a beautiful script
and the lookbook was be like it's so
it's so beautiful and and true to the
cinematography and the film like the
script is also a stunning it's a
beautiful script and obviously it's
really funny and ridiculous but but it's
beautifully written and um I think that
I was most nervous about being able to
to do a good job at it um because you
don't you can't it can't be silly and
and of course it is silly but you know
you they need to be believable and it
needs to in order for all those those
beats to work work and for it to work
you have to be you know uh believable as
a Sasquatch and that's not something
that was in my wheelhouse at the time so
I think I was honestly most um curious
if I could do it and then I met with
them and I just loved I mean I'd already
met them before but I I love their work
and I love them so I kind of just like
you know decided to give it a shot
that's one of the best qualities of the
movie the fact that it it like offers
laugh out loud moments but there's
always an earnestness to it all that
make sure that you establish like a real
connection with these characters and you
care about them I was very impressed by
that um yeah I think the the
conversation that I had I I I got I
don't remember if it was the I think it
was maybe the full script and also the
lookbook and it just seemed like such a
such a real project that wasn't um
tongue and cheek or trying to be fake or
trying to be silly for silly sake um and
then the conversation that I had with
David and Nathan um it just I felt like
we jelled so well or I I understood what
they were kind of trying to go for and I
was so into signing on to something that
was wacky and also serious we I I'm
remember we actually had this
conversation about how heartbreaking
like watching your dog can be oh yeah
you remember that and you had your dog
with I had my dog with me and and then
that sort of was the essence of you know
finding the characters of these sasat of
the Sasquatch family you know and I and
then I think in that moment I was like
that would be such a incredible thing to
try and get to do as an actor to play a
animal
person um that that make that you you
know evokes those kinds of feelings yeah
so that makes so much sense as a as a
cat and dog lover I feel like that
immediately just clicked in my brain the
way you described it bringing up the
script made me curious what does the
dialogue look like on the page um
there's no there's no dialogue it's just
it talks about where they grunt you know
and and it talks about what they
conveying in the in in the grunts so and
uh so it gets very specific on the
information they're conveying but yeah
it's done through their language when
the time is right I'd be so curious to
read that script and see the lookbook oh
yeah release some extra materials when
the time is right um David and Nathan
for both of you how does your approach
to directing your actors change when
your actors are essentially carrying
around a significant amount of you know
FX hair makeup and costumes well I I
think like for
uh for Nathan he was kind of he's he's
been doing the the Sasquatch stick for a
long time since we were kids he he's
just like dialed into ape mode um and
then um you know and then like like
Christ when we talked with Kristoff we
we is very clear he got the you know the
tone and and and Riley as well and then
and we we never had any question you
know Riley would would be able to dial
into this role because I think one of
the things we we've always loved about
her films is no matter what she's in
she's always it always feels very
genuine and very very present and and
and real no matter what type of role it
is like that's seen that consistency
throughout and so like oh my God if we
can bring that that that groundedness to
to this creature it would it would be
incredible so is there any b-roll of you
dressed as your Sasquatch directing the
movie I have some I have quite a bit of
that I mean yeah because there was there
was a few days especially where I was
you know shooting the be the morning or
even in the afternoon but we every body
got in a costume and so yeah it's like
me behind the camera with David and I'm
in just my full makeup and uh I feel
like he was staying in costume like in
solidarity because mostly because
because it was tough but it was it was I
think everybody got normalized to these
suits and the the look so quickly it was
it was I forgot that I was wearing it
sometimes and and everybody else would
it was just like talking uh to to me
normally I think yeah we were definitely
we were getting directed by by one
person in One Sasquatch yeah one one one
one human that was cackling like an
idiot a very Earnest Sasquatch it's
funny how normalized it how quickly it
got for for both the cast and crew cuz
we're we're joking like like I remember
a couple times in sh we're like if
someone just wandered into this set and
we were just so like nonplused by
everything I know there were some people
like we'd lock off the roads but there
were sometimes like people would drive
through and we'd be sitting on the
streets in our like cast chairs with our
Sasquatch faces on and then like our
jackets
dream true why can't I drive by a set
like that um Nathan the answer to this
question might be no but I was just
talking to another actor director who
explained his process of directing his
actors this way where sometimes he's
able to direct his scene Partners
through his performance where he can
make certain choices with his characters
in order to spark new choices in the
people he's acting opposite did you ever
do that here um not intentionally I
think everybody like the big thing was
you know the the tone of this film being
so specific and once we met everybody
everybody on the crew H got that right
away and it just enabled everybody to
have a a huge you know sandbox to play
in once we were on set so you know it
wasn't like we had to push things a
certain direction or or whatever it was
more of like you know this is what the
scene is going to be about and then the
mannerisms and stuff kind of just just
when you were in those suits it just
kind of flowed out of you and so it was
it was it the scenes kind of had that
sort of Rhythm to it where it's like all
right this is what we're going to do and
and we didn't really have to like do a
lot of specific you know Corrections or
directions or or anything like that it
was more mostly um you know just it felt
like like a really fun adventure you
know yeah it was the I think because
everyone was so dialed into the tone it
was the most collaborative thing we've
ever done so I it would made made our
job easy cuz we you know if we didn't
have to Puppeteer anyone we could just
sit back and everyone could you know
work within those boundaries and
everyone kind of knew when it was
working or wasn't with that in mind I
know this is a very unique movie but is
there anything about the process of
making Sasquatch Sunset that you think
you're going to apply to your next film
even if it doesn't feature a whole
family of
Sasquatch uh too early to tell I think
you should turn this into an anthology
and the sequel should be I don't know
like a family of Yeti or
something who knows cousin I like to
speak what I want into existence um you
were kind of joking about this when we
were slating earlier but were there any
names for them or even like code names
that you would use to refer to each
character on set um yeah I think like M
mine we just called the alphas Sasquatch
because he was more of the the
stereotypical you know brooding sort of
face um
um and then yeah the rest of the
family kind of we would just refer to
like the the child or you know Jesse was
the the the the mother Sasquatch feel
like set like you were the only one that
had a character name it was Alpha and
then we were all like Riley and Jesse
and and
Kristoff enough it works you transformed
the most I'm so fascinated by your work
with movement uh movement coach I think
someone Jesse had brought in for the uh
production can you maybe each give us
like I don't know like a pillar or
specific technique you learn from this
movement coach that everyone will be
able to see you applying to your work in
the finished
film you guys want Riley has some good
really what just like when we we we had
this Zoom session with the movement
coach and everybody was supposed to like
get into this sort of a primate sort of
animal mindset and just sort of walk
around your room or your space and pick
up things and discover them and and a
lot of that turned into putting stuff in
your
mouth yeah we we did like first we did
Zoom rehearsals and I was really nervous
in the zoom rehearsals yeah and and then
once we got in the room with each other
it was actually it was less stressful
but it was you know I think that that he
kind of uh he really helped with our
walk that was something that was super
helpful like to make our our walk our
walk uh we had the same walk but
obviously we have different characters
but the Walk of like that the famous
Sasquatch video and the pose you sort of
see them Frozen in like we kind of took
that and turned it into a a movement you
know and he really helped with that um
and then just the finding the you know
how human and how how ape to to be was
interesting um I think we all landed in
different places a little bit which I
think was also fine because we're making
up whatever we want yeah it made his
character distinctive in that way I mean
I remember early on one of the like
maybe after one of the first like
rehearsal sessions we had like that
Riley was like remember you said I think
my character should be the most feral
and we're like okay I just felt like on
the sort of like the scale of evolution
she was the most behind that
was most advanced the most advanced I
was going to say that was kind of my
impression by the end it's it's it was
my choice I stick by it it was a great
one I I think it was interesting working
with Lauren um learning how to pick
things up with your whole like not not
with not using your fingertips but like
grasping more like with your with your
hand and then um uh when we were talking
about just just putting things in our
mouth it was kind of not oh and you also
sent um uh we got some some references
of uh Apes that were just kind of using
their eyes to look around instead of
kind of like neck movements and stuff
like that so there was a lot of there
was a lot of um uh influence from lot of
YouTube deep we got sent like they had
obviously done their homework and we got
sent like a huge list of um videos and
sounds and all these things so it was
kind of like combining all of them which
was cool and then also watch watching um
2001 Space Odyssey um the beginning and
yeah just kind of mix adding it all I
love the creative possibilities with a
film like this I want to see more movies
that are made this way one very brief
question before I have to let you go can
you give me the exact translation of
anything we see or hear in the film like
I basically want something to repeat
until everybody can experience the movie
if you know what I mean like whether
it's a grunt or one of the hand motions
that they do like I feel like when
you're watching the movie you understand
exactly what it means but I want to
transl somebody asked me today what the
um banging on the tree meant can I say
that yeah oh and that was sort of like a
call to see if there were other
Sasquatch around I like that one yeah
more Sasquatch I don't know make a Yeti
movie there's so many creatures out
there that you can make a movie about
yeah we'd love to Anthology series I am
willing it into existence right now
thank you for your time thank you for
your movie thank you to filo and thanks
to everybody out there watching keep an
eye out for Sasquatch Sunset and stay
tuned more from Sundance 2024 for you
soon